Oh
[Music]
Entertainment Tonight has crossed some
major YouTube milestones 800,000
subscribers and 1 billion historic views
this is an exciting day
I gotta go share this news can't go out
that way you think I know by now oh yeah
[Applause]
welcome back to behind the screens the
show where we get to talk about whatever
we want but mostly Star Wars I'm er so
sorry cut I am so sorry to interrupt you
ash um I brought you some movie theater
candy because we are on behind the
screens well also we are celebrating
hitting 800,000 subscribers on et's
YouTube channel and a billion historic
views do you have a message out for the
fans watching this show I did not know
that many people I you know I feel like
the luckiest one in the world I get to
come here every day and talk about Star
Wars and weird rom-coms and just fangirl
out like basically like just be myself
and I love you guys so much and thank
you for supporting me and my weirdo poor
Ignatian self because and we're done No
thank you so much I got a hit off the
rest of the shows enjoy the candy fun
interrupting everybody
[Music]
hey river babes welcome back to another
episode of sweet water secrets we're
gonna be bringing us order up hi hi hi
my bag okay I have exciting news I'm not
sure if you heard but we have reached
800,000 subscribers on our YouTube
channel
and 1 billion historic God I just wanna
do you have a message out there for the
vixens oh my gosh well vixens I'm so
glad that you guys love Riverdale as
much as I do thank you so much for
helping us get you a billion views and
if you help us get to a million
subscribers I'll give you even more
Riverdale steamy Cubs oh I love it but
that's it thank you so much so sorry
intrepid vibe back to this week's
episode
[Music]
welcome to certified country I'm so wysz
Lacey and today we're with the boys of
Florida girl I know you're not sorry
you're with me today
oh sorry to interrupt I don't know if
you heard the good news but we have
reached 800,000 subscribers on our
channel and I am feeling historic views
I had to athlete given a message out
there for all those country fans
watching her shows country is strong
y'all thank you guys so much for
watching I mean this show has been so
much fun and between you know harassing
the boys of FGL Blake Shelton's and
drinking with them on their knees on a
drink with them I'm getting paid to live
my best life so thank you guys
Thank You Danny thank you for let me
crash kitchen you carry on
all right I'm so sorry to interrupt I
have some good news to share we have
reached 800,000 subscribers on our
YouTube channel and a billion historic
view so I'm stopping by everywhere do
you have a message out there for
everyone watches how to Hollywood oh my
gosh well we have special guest Linda's
avid celebrity makeup artist here and
thank you guys so much for watching and
being a part of the community and our
channel thank you okay I have one more
stop to make so I gotta go but it's time
for roses and Rosie I'm sorry to
interrupt you know we have something to
celebrate
we're just perfect cuz you have
champagne so pour one out for me while I
explain we have reached 800,000
subscribers to our YouTube channel and
hit 1 billion historic views Lauren this
is a huge deal you have a message out
there for the fans and bachelor nation
oh my god what a perfect day for rosacea
champagne a historic date you guys I
just want to say thank you because I
used to watch bachelor shows drunk and
alone and you guys have validated my
existence by watching with me thank you
for all the views bachelor nation and
YouTube community I love you cheers to
that
Cheers uh I gotta go carry on bang
whoa I forgot that girl can drink rose'
like nobody's business guys just want to
say thank you so much for subscribing to
our channel we really could not have
gotten here without you and all those
shows you just saw we're made for the
fan but we're only getting started so
please like comment share let us know
what kind of stories you want to hear
what kind of what kind of videos you
want to see and we'll make it happen you
guys cheers to a billion views and 800
subscribers and thank you